poco a poco empieza a restablecerse el
tráfico de pasajeros y de bienes entre
francia el reino unido ha suspendido
desde el domingo luego de que gran
bretaña encontrará una variante del
corona virus que se expande mucho más
rápido hasta un 70% los pasajeros que
quieran ingresar a ese país deben
presentar una prueba negativa del
coronavirus 72 horas antes del viaje hay
prioridad de viaje para los residentes y
los nacionales en el caso de los
conductores de las tractomulas y de los
camiones grandes la logística es más
difícil funcionarios del sistema
nacional de salud y soldados del
ejército están empezando a hacer estos
test sin embargo en el puerto de dover
la situación es muy compleja hay más de
3.000 conductores que están aparcados
con sus camiones a lo largo y ancho de
este puerto en el reino unido- tratando
de encontrar una solución ha habido
confusión no saben a dónde deben hacerse
el test y ha habido ya enfrentamientos
con la policía porque lo único que
quieren estos conductores en la mayoría
ciudadanos europeos quieren es volver a
sus casas para la navidad así que la
situación está muy
por la logística y seguramente pasarán
algunos días antes de que esta situación
en el puerto de dover pueda solucionarse